et nous accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20 heures ce soir férouz
bendouiou bonsoir
alors faire au jeu le 8 juillet 1987
votre soeur chahrazed âgé de 10 ans
disparaît dans un sous sol de votre hlm
à bourgoin jallieu ni elle ni son corps
n'ont été retrouvés elle fait partie des
disparus de l'isère une affaire qui
vient à nouveau de faire la une avec la
destruction par la justice d'un certain
nombre de corps comme de vulgaires
scellé tout à fait
on passe maintenant à notre invité du
samedi
[Musique]
fait rozoy bonsoir le jour votre vie a
basculé vous aviez 11 ans et demi et
votre soeur chahrazed en avait 10 nous
sommes le 8 juillet 1987 à bourgoin
jallieu dans l'isère il est environ 13
heures chahrazed veut sortir jouer avec
ses copains mais votre mère ne la laisse
pas sortir seul sans vous sauf que vous
ce jour là vous êtes scotché devant les
programmes jeunesse de la télé
chahrazed insiste et votre mère finit
par céder à une condition c'est que
charazed descendent la poubelle
on retrouvera la poubelle mais pas
chahrazed
chahrazed ne remontent pas dans un
premier temps personne ne s'inquiète on
est des enfants on a envie de jouer
c'est les vacances scolaires donc non on
s'inquiète pas ce qui nous met la puce à
l'oreille en fait c'est un orage qui
aurait éclaté à peu près une heure et
demie après et comme consigne en fait
quand on était tout petit c'était de
rentrer des kebano rage pour se protéger
bien sûr et la voyant pas arriver ma
mère l'envoie chez les voisins pour u2
la récupérer en me disant c'est bon tu
veux rentrer quoi alors chez le voisin
vous la trouvez pas vous décidez d'aller
vérifier la piscine rien à ce moment là
les parents du quartier commence à être
prévenu tout le monde cherche tout le
monde s'inquiète on appelle la police et
la réaction incroyable de la police qui
qui vous dis arrêtez d'occuper les
lignes et arrêter de faire des blagues
au téléphone qui fait arrêter de jouer
que le téléphone que c'était pas rigolo
et qu'il y avait des choses plus
importantes à gérer la police finalement
n'arrivera qu'à 18h30 parce que ils ont
commencé à ressentir qu'en fait tout le
quartier commence à mobiliser alors là
les recherches commencent à s'organiser
sérieusement il ya des battus on fouille
les étangs il ya des chiens pisteurs qui
sont mis sur le coup beaucoup de moyens
mis en oeuvre mais aucun résultat aucun
témoignage aucun signalement d'un
individu suspect rien tout le temps
avançait plus la nuit tombée et plus on
s'inquiétait et à partir de là tout le
monde s'est mis réellement à fouiner de
partout
alors évidemment votre vie de famille à
l'époque et est bouleversée par cette
tragédie
le vide laissé par l'absence de charazed
prend une classe immense elle devient
une ombre dans cette famille d'autant
plus grande qu'elle est à bout personne
n'ose évoquer sa manche et vous à
l'époque je crois que c'est pas une
question taboue c'est plus une question
de de douleur qui était tellement
épaisse tellement lourde qui occupait
carrément tout l'espace on va dire de la
maison que peu de mots le moindre mot
concernant chahrazed provoquer
un effondrement de l'âme énorme alors
vous grandissez dans ce silence dans
cette culpabilité évidemment vous dites
pourquoi est-ce que je suis pas descendu
avec chahrazed ce jour là quoi ouaip et
enfin d'un programme télévision qu'en
vacances en l'occurrence et depuis c'est
vrai que qu'est ce qui se serait passé
si j'y étais allé à sa place si j'étais
allé avec elle
aujourd'hui vous vous dites qu à cette
époque vous auriez aimé avoir quelques
années de plus pour pouvoir tenir tête à
la police et la justice en effet ce qui
s'est passé ce qu'elle sans doute
aggraver la situation c'est que vos
parents sondés sont des immigrés il
parle pas bien français et l'enquète en
pâtit mes parents sont d'origine
algérienne sont arrivés en france très
jeune ils ont toujours travaillé et il
parle très mal il
le lisent pas du tout donc du coup ils
ont eu du mal à s'exprimer a expliqué la
situation et
c'est grave parce qu'à l'époque j'ai
vraiment senti qu'ils avaient
un mépris visé par rapport à eux en fait
et du coup c'est vrai que je me suis dit
à cet âge là mais pourquoi je suis pas
plus vieille pourquoi moi je peux pas y
aller et taper du poing dix ans
maintenant des c'est pas parce qu'ils
comprennent pas qu'il faut les prendre
pour des imbéciles quoi c'est quand même
des êtres humains ils ont perdu
quelqu'un très important il faut les
aider comme on est tout le monde aucun
soutien psychologique la seule personne
que vous voyez à l'époque c'est une
assistante sociale
la mère qui était très contente lui
ouvre la porte presque lembras parce que
c'est enfin et à quelqu'un qui arrive et
qui va m'aider donc elle l'a fait
rentrer la dame ait dit oui je viens
pour faire signer un document dans quoi
mr très contente et s'est dit ça y est
on va me traiter un peu d'argent que je
puisse au moins faire mener les
investigations
privées peut-être mais des
investigations qui pourraient nous aider
à retrouver charade elle est là la dame
lui dit oui non mais attendez je vous
faire signer un document et le 10 mai
signée signé ma mère agrippine qu'est ce
que c'est et là vous avez la sensation
qui dit bah en fait c'est pour arrêter
les allocations familiales une semaine
après alors la famille est complètement
exclu de l'enquète par la police et
quand votre terme au commissariat ils
disent carrément arrêter de nous
emmerder carrément mon père est allé
tous les jours au commissariat pour
essayer de récupérer des informations
pour apporter les siennes parce qu'il a
il a cherché encore et encore il s'est
arrêté de travailler pour pouvoir
cherchez de partout seul en voiture il a
fait des kilomètres pas possible et
à chaque fois qu'il allait au
commissariat pour demander à ce que son
était est bas au début on disait qu'on
allait rappeler râpé et vers la fin
sincèrement là carrément jetés on l'a
dit c'est pas la peine de venir plus
désolé monsieur bendouiou vous ne venez
plus à rien les avertira en temps et en
heure et alors quand votre famille
demande à voir le dossier vous être
envoyé sur grenoble ensuite de grenoble
à bourgoin de bourgoin lyon enfin
finalement vous êtes perdus devant cette
administration on n'a jamais su où était
le dossier de charazed on ne savait pas
du tout qu'ils sont occupés on savait
pas si cet adversaire pj de lyon on
savait pas si c'était le commissariat on
savait pas c'est gendarmerie et dès
qu'on allait vers l'un ou vers l'autre
il nous renvoyait en fait vers l'un
envers l'autre 1 donc on n'a jamais su
alors en 2003 la sphère rebondi quand
vous apprenez que le dossier de charazed
est fermé depuis 1989 vous apprenez 15
ans après qu'en fait dossier était a été
clos et personne n'a averti la famille
personne
j'ai commencé à voir la puce à l'oreille
en fait vers l'âge de 17 18 ans parce
que j'avais passé mon permis de conduire
et je me suis rendu au commissariat de
bourgoin-jallieu justement parce que
j'avais besoin d'un autre jeune
documents et de là je rencontre
l'enquêteur qui s'est occupé du dossier
de ma soeur et en voyant il s'assoit
derrière son bureau et il me regarde les
faits vous avez retrouvé sur az
moi je le regarde comme ça je suis dit
mais attendez monsieur ça fait un petit
moment qu'on essaie de vendre les
informations vous avais dit de ne plus
revenir à chaque fois qu'on perd est
venu vous l'avez jetez vous pouvez pas
maintenant c'est ça comme ça le dossier
d'encours en principe on recherche me
dis bah moi je suis au courant de rien
voilà donc depuis 1989 chahrazed n'est
plus dans les fichiers des personnes
disparues donc ça veut dire que si un
corps d'enfant mort et retrouvé il n'y a
pas de possibilité de faire le lien il
n'y a aucun lien possible parce que les
gendarmes ne sont pas informés et une
missive qui leur apparaît quand une
personne qui est porté disparu avec les
informations nécessaires la ce a pas été
le cas donc depuis 1989 jusqu'en 2003
elle n'a absolument jamais jamais été
inscrit sur le fichier des personnes
recherchées
donc elle n'a jamais été recherchées
donc on l'a jamais trouvé
alors en 2005 vous êtes convoqué par le
procureur donc l'appareil vous vous
dites tiens il se passe peut-être un
truc voilà vous êtes excité vous y allez
est arrivé là bas devant le bureau en
fait il me regarde et me dit bon ben
voilà en fait j'aime vous annoncer que
en boucle le dossier on a fini y a rien
d'intéressant on n'y a rien donc c'est
pas la peine et après ils me regardent
et puis me dit puis surtout surtout vous
éviter dans la presse parce que je
comprends pas pourquoi vous avez écrit
mon nom comme ça il ya un daeu il n'a
pas je ne sais plus et voilà et donc là
je regarde comme ça complètement hébété
jeudi mais vous m'avez fait venir pour
ça
et là je suis reparti mais complètement
un
député rebelote on recommence vous êtes
très déterminés à vous commencez à vous
adresser aux médias vous créez un site
internet vous prenez enfin une avocate
ce qui effectivement d'un seul coup
simplifie beaucoup les choses et vous
obtenez la création d'une cellule
baptisée mineurs 38 donc qui est chargé
de retrouver ses neuf mineurs disparus
dans l'isère 38 c'est le nom de
départements d'isère il ya un numéro
vert qui est créée il ya une douzaine
d'enquêteurs qui sont mis sur le coup
parce que terrible c'est que le fait que
le numéro vert soit hors service vous
l'apprenez complètement par hasard
c'était lors d'une émission
radio café de cannelle voilà et donc on
nous demandait un peu d'expliquer de
relater les faits donc j'ai expliqué
tout moment donné je fais mon appel à
témoins comme je le fais à chaque fois
parce qu'il me semble très important
parce que personne n'a relancé ce fameux
numéro donc personne ne me connaît donc
personne ne peut nous renvoyer des
informations régulièrement dès que je
passe dans les médias je l' annonce est
là le monsieur m baden beaucoup et là il
me dit non mais
madame bendouiou le numéro il n'est plus
activé depuis six semaines
et là je tombe des nues style mais c'est
impossible on n'est pas au courant
l'auteur de ces crimes est le même pour
tous et un oeuf donc c'est pour ça qu'on
a mélangé
pour justement essayer de voir si
c'était une seule personne qui avait
commis de ce crime ou si c'était
plusieurs voilà donc c'était
de trouver le maximum de renseignements
pour pouvoir faire des corrélations
possible entre les dossiers parce que
neuf fois centre où j'étais quand même
beaucoup c'est trop une fois c'est trop
et puis voilà l affaire rebondit une
dernière fois donc lorsque la justice
détruit 11 corps considérés comme des
scellés comme de vulgaires scellé ça
c'est un rapport avec un dossier qui
instruit justement également par le
cabinet seban il concerne ludovic
janvier qui est porté disparu depuis
1983 l'ue devait jamais là jamais te
retrouver non plus lorient 85 et des
ossements qui ont été découverts par des
spéléologues et on a demandé du fait de
la sélune en 38 de faire des
rapprochements justement avec ludovic et
ses fameuses ossements et un moment
donné on nous a dit en fait
les ossements les a pas parce qu'ils ont
été détruits parce qu'en france on a le
droit au bout d'un certain temps quand
les dossiers sont clos de détruire des
cds et donc on a dit attention des
scellés même si les affaires sont
élucidées c'est dur pour nous de
l'accepter mais que l'on détruise des
corps parce qu'avant d'être des
ossements c'était quand même un corps
d'enfant je précise plus que des
ossements d'enfants mais oui c'est à son
enfant et de là en fait on a récupéré
une fameuse liste et dans cette liste il
y avait les ossements du vercors et
d'autres sur les autres lignes vous
aviez x femmes
retrouvez telle date détruit lui des
clans donc oui c'est ça voilà détruits
et s'allongent jusqu'à 11 donc voilà on
cherche à savoir
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il faut dire
que hu michèle alliot marie s'est élevé
contre ça évidemment michèle alliot
marie a été la seule personne humaine
dans cette histoire en fait en dix ans
mais c'est pas possible en france est
illégal de détruire des corps humain
puisque vous pensez que votre soeur
peut-être dans ces corps qui ont été
détenues sur ce que comme je les dis
plutôt elle n'a pas été recherché depuis
89 jusqu'en 2003
alors aujourd'hui charazed disparue
depuis 23 ans pourquoi continuez vous le
combat féroce parce que je la retrouver
je vous cache pas que
quand on lit tous ces dossiers
je n'imagine pas vivante
mais il faut dire aussi que ce sont
toutes des affaires qui ont été donnés
ici des et qu'en france aujourd'hui
peut-être s'ils sont pas décédées il ya
encore les assassins l'un qui sont en
train de se promener tranquillement et
c'est inacceptable
vous dites tant que charazed reposera
pas en paix je serai en vigueur
tant qu'elle sera pas enterré dignement
je continuerai à me battre et je
continuerai à me battre également pour
toutes ces personnes parce que on oublie
dans cette histoire de scandale des
ossements qui ont été détruites et des
cadavres qui ont été détruits que la
question essentielle c'est se dire qui
sont ces douze personnes
vous arrivez à travailler à avoir une
vie normale à côté de ça
alors vos parents eux croient qu'un jour
chahrazed va frapper à la porte et les
serrer dans ses bras qu'ils y croient
toujours pour mes parents pour un grand
nombre de ma famille c'est très
difficile de
s'avouer probablement décédées pour eux
c'est plus rassurant de se dire bon on
va la retrouver elle va arriver elle va
frapper à la porte et
mais vous voyez derrière ça il ya aussi
la question de
du conseil de l'assistance et de l'aide
aux victimes qui n'existent pas parce
que en fait on voit bien que
il ya des grandes carences en la matière
et ce dont on a besoin quand on est face
à une telle tragédie face à un tel drame
c'est qu'on puisse répondre à vos
questions bien merci de votre témoignage
dans tous les cafés rose mercier et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux